bene devo ammettere pubblicamente
davanti a circa mille persone che o
volontariamente scelto una fotografia in
cui sono ma molto ma molto più giovane
[Applauso]
nei prossimi quindici minuti parleremo
di sanità e salute e non sarà una
presentazione divertente sarà una
presentazione tragica a volte drammatica
perché perché chi ha la fortuna come me
di lavorare come medico e di fare
ricerca sa molto bene che noi al di
fuori dei nostri delle nostre conferenze
scientifiche non veniamo mai chiamati in
situazioni come questa se tutto va bene
la nostra presenza è sempre associata a
qualcosa che nel mondo della salute va
male quindi cominciamo subito con
cercare di eliminare un falso mito il
nostro corpo non è puro noi non siamo
sterili all'interno del nostro organismo
noi abbiamo più di mille specie
batteriche alcune buone ed altre cattive
che vivono in un perfetto equilibrio di
uno a uno per ogni cellula umana c'è una
cellula batterica
questo ci permette di vivere in salute
ma attenzione questa questo equilibrio è
indispensabile ma non è sufficiente per
vivere in perfetta salute perché perché
quello che sappiamo adesso è che la
nostra salute e la derivazione di tre
momenti differenti
noi possiamo vivere in quella che si
chiama one else che molto difficile
tradurre in italiano sarebbe la salute
con la s maiuscola all unità di salute
che è solo ed esclusivamente quando
tutto quello che viene fatto nel mondo
animale nel mondo vegetale e sugli
esseri umani nel campo della salute è in
perfetto equilibrio
quindi se per esempio io faccio un
intervento di salute sugli animali senza
considerare le conseguenze sull'uomo
questo sicuramente romperà questo
equilibrio e porterà ad alcune patologie
per lo più di tipo infettivo e qual è
l'allarme che esiste in questo momento
in italia per la rottura di questo
equilibrio sono le infezioni antibiotico
resistenti cosa sono le infezioni
antibiotico resistenti sono quelle
infezioni causate da batteri
che non rispondono più a nessun
antibiotico presenti al momento sul
mercato
questi dati che provengono da un centro
di controllo per le malattie infettive
europeo che si chiama i sì di sì e che a
stoccolma approvato per l'europa nel
2015 quindi attenzione sicuramente i
dati spostati al 2019 sono molto più
importanti ma nel 2015 in europa sono
state documentate più di 600 mila
infezioni causate da batteri antibiotico
resistenti e 33 mila decessi di questi
33 mila decessi più di 10.000 si sono
verificati solo in italia e io sono
sicura che la maggior parte di voi non
aveva nessuna informazione
a questo proposito questo è quello che
io chiamo hilux unami silente della
sanità italiana quando su una mortalità
di 33 mila morti un terzo si verifica in
una sola nazione europea e con noi c'è
solamente la grecia perché tutto il
resto dell'europa in particolare il nord
europa ha un numero di morti
estremamente inferiore
vuol dire che chiaramente c'è un
problema qual è il problema difficile
dirlo in 15 minuti ma ho scelto di
raccontarvi la storia di due donne
la prima donna si chiama maria vittoria
nasce nel 1924 a verona da una nobile
famiglia è una bella ragazza un po
gracile e si sposa molto molto presto
con il giovane pupillo del direttore
dell'ospedale un medico estremamente
promettente che decide di ricoverare la
hbo la moglie quando sta per avere un
bambino non era normale a quei tempi ma
lui voleva proteggerla perché la vedeva
come ho detto prima piuttosto gracile il
24 marzo nasce francesco giuseppe figlio
maschio in ottima salute
sono tutti estremamente felici purtroppo
poche ore prima che maria vittoria lasci
l'ospedale si sente sempre più debole a
uno svenimento parte una febbre
elevatissima comincia ad avere i brividi
scontenti perde completamente conoscenza
peggiora in 72 ore
riesce a risvegliarsi una sola volta
per pochi minuti vedere suo figlio e
poco dopo morire cos'è che ha causato la
morte di maria vittoria e questo
batterio si chiama staphylococcus aureus
è un batterio che probabilmente è
penetrato nel sangue di maria vittoria
dalle mani dell'ostetrica non
perfettamente lavate e a quel tempo non
c'era nessuna terapia per proteggere gli
organi interni di maria vittoria ed è
stato anche molto sfortunata perché
perché pochi mesi dopo arriva in italia
in tutta europa e anche nel resto del
mondo
la penicillina che non è il cocktail
dell'attore famoso di cui prima ma
fortunatamente non essendo un cocktail
ha permesso di salvare come dice questo
manifesto un manifesto vero inglese del
periodo subito dopo la guerra grazie
alla penicillina i nostri soldati sono
tornati a casa perché perché la
penicillina ha potuto curare le
infezioni delle ferite che i soldati
avevano avuto durante la seconda guerra
mondiale
dopo la penicillina arrivano molti altri
antibiotici e ci saranno tantissime
infezioni che verranno curate grazie a
questi antibiotici saranno tantissime
marie vittorie laura sofia marco
giovanni che verranno ricoverati e
potranno tornare a casa
sembrerebbe una storia a lieto fine in
realtà non è così e nonostante negli
anni settanta qualcuno abbia detto
finalmente con gli antibiotici abbiamo
debellato le malattie infettive non è
successo e la situazione è molto più
grave
la seconda donna si chiama sofia bella
ragazza questa volta non nasce da una
famiglia ricca perché le malattie
infettive non hanno correlazione con il
reddito e nasce invece a milano dal
quartiere di isola a 24 anni si ricovera
per un amp di ceto mia in un ospedale di
milano siamo all'inizio degli anni 2000
non non si prevedevano problemi
particolari purtroppo qualche ora dopo
l'intervento sofia presenta gli stessi
sintomi
di maria vittoria febbre elevata brivido
scuote ipotensione la trasportano
immediatamente rianimazione perché
adesso abbiamo molte più possibilità che
nel 43 e viene collegata addirittura ad
un monitor viene collegata ad un monitor
ad un apparecchio che le permette di
respirare
nonostante tutto questo dieci giorni di
agonia e sofia muore perché muore sofia
perché nel suo sangue c'è la klebsiella
pneumoniae questo batterio era
resistente a tutte le terapie
antibiotiche presenti sul mercato in
italia in quel momento perché siamo
arrivati a questo per due motivi
fondamentali primo l'utilizzo di
antibiotici in maniera eccessiva
sull'uomo e sugli animali ha provocato
una pressione sui batteri e ne ha
favorito lo sviluppo di resistenza non
esiste nessun antibiotico che non
provochi resistenza prima o poi ci sono
antibiotici che provocano resistenza
dopo poche ore dalla messa in commercio
e alcuni altri antibiotici che lo
provocano dopo cinque anni ma non esiste
un antibiotico senza resistenza e qual è
l'altro grosso enorme problema che
abbiamo oggi che le case farmaceutiche
non producono più antibiotici sono
vent'anni e anche questo sono sicura che
molti pochi di voi lo sanno
sono più di vent'anni che nessuna casa
farmaceutica produce un antibiotico che
abbia una molecola nuova significa che
tutto quello che è stato messo sul
mercato negli ultimi 20 anni ha una
semplice piccola modifica a livello di
costituzione dell'antibiotico che quindi
facilita lo sviluppo di resistenza
perché le case farmaceutiche non sono
interessate e credo che sia ovvia la
risposta perché non è interessante
economicamente molto meglio investire in
farmaci per il diabete molto meglio
investire su chemioterapia rispetto alla
terapia antibiotica e questa è la
situazione dell'italia per la klebsiella
oggi questi sono i dati sempre degli
easy dissi di cui parlavo prima cosa
significa questo rosso che per cento
persone come sophia che hanno la club
sia la polonia nel sangue oggi nei
nostri ospedali
più del 50 per cento non ha possibilità
di risposta agli antibiotici in
commercio cosa possiamo fare sono una
persona estremamente ottimista quando le
persone del mio team sia qui che in
germania vengono da me mi dicono che c'è
un problema io non vedo il problema
ma cerco di focalizzare immediatamente
sulle soluzioni e sicuramente ci sono
delle soluzioni
direi che sono tre livelli di soluzioni
le prime due legislativo e medico sono
nelle nostre mani questo è quello che
noi facciamo ogni giorno che i nostri
gruppi di ricerca
lavoriamo con la ms lavoriamo con gli
studi si lavoriamo con l'america abbiamo
lavorato con il g7 con il g20 per
cercare di avere dei documenti e dei
progetti che convincano le case
farmaceutiche a produrre più antibiotici
cos'altro facciamo lavoriamo negli
ospedali con quello che probabilmente
molti di voi hanno sentito come
stewardship antibiotica cos'è lo steward
quello che vi accompagna quando entrate
sull'aereo quindi noi facciamo dei
programmi che aiutano i medici a
prescrivere meglio gli antibiotici e in
questo orgogliosamente dico che qui a
verona in questo momento abbiamo dei
progetti distinguersi per la terapia
antibiotica che sono all'avanguardia in
italia e in europa
ma quello che a me interessa di più oggi
è quello che potete fare voi voi e noi
come cittadini ed esistono quattro cose
essenziali in cui la vostra
partecipazione è fondamentale prima di
tutto il primo livello e quello
legislativo
voi dovete pretendere che la sanità e il
problema delle infezioni antibiotico
resistenti che non sono un problema solo
nostro ma è un problema che ci sarà per
le future azioni per le generazioni
future sia nel programma di governo
l'italia in una situazione estremamente
strana la sanità e il problema delle
infezioni ospedaliere antibiotico
resistenti e all'interno di tutti i
programmi di governo degli altri paesi
ci sono state delle elezioni in
inghilterra che sono state vinte
perché
il gop il partito che ha vinto aveva il
miglior programma per ridurre il
problema delle infezioni antibiotico
resistenti
questa è una nostra scelta e dobbiamo
ripeto pretendere di vedere cosa fanno e
pretendere di vederne i risultati
il secondo punto è quando siamo dal
nostro medico per avere la prescrizione
di un antibiotico
ricordatevi sempre l'antibiotico deve
essere assunto solo se prescritto
quindi se per esempio vi ritrovate tre
compresse perché purtroppo non abbiamo
ancora convinto le case farmaceutiche a
produrre delle confezioni che siano
equivalenti ai dosaggi che voi dovete
prendere se io vi prescrivo sette giorni
di terapia per un'infezione urinaria e
nella scatola ci sono dieci giorni di
terapia non pensate che se avete di
nuovo i sintomi dell'infezione orinaria
potete iniziare a prendere quelle tre
compresse perché la terapia non è sempre
la stessa
e se voi assumete antibiotici non sotto
controllo medico o se interrompere la
terapia troppo precocemente il vostro
intestino il vostro microbioma come si
dice oggi a livello intestinale verrà
completamente modificato e voi sarete
più soggetti ad infezioni antibiotico
resistenti terzo livello l'utilizzo di
antibiotici negli animali non è sotto
controllo perché vengono utilizzate gli
antibiotici negli animali perché se un
animale assumi antibiotici ha un peso
maggiore
ed è per questo che vengono utilizzati
gli antibiotici cosa possiamo fare noi
come cittadini comprare e controllare
che la carne che mangiamo in particolare
quella di pollo esistono numerosi studi
che dicono che lo stesso tipo di batteri
con lo stesso ge nome dna è stato
trovato nei polli e contemporaneamente
nel sangue delle persone che avevano
delle infezioni con lo stesso tipo di
batteri quindi controllate accuratamente
che quello che voi mangiate provenga da
colture biologiche oggi possono scrivere
sulle confezioni dove non si usano
antibiotici negli allevamenti
ultimo punto ma molto importante
attenzione a leggere igiene delle mani
sembra banale s
iniziale essenziale quando andate in
ospedale essenziale quando uscite
dall'ospedale essenziale all'interno
della vostra famiglia nella prevenzione
c'è anche la vaccinazione
la vaccinazione delle fasce più deboli
dei pazienti fragili
pensate la vaccinazione per l'influenza
non serve solo a proteggere dall
influenza il paziente di 70 anni
significa che se non avrà all'influenza
non dovrà prendere antibiotici
a seguire per le infezioni batteriche
che sono più frequenti in chi ha avuto
l'influenza
cosa succede se noi non facciamo questo
questa è la mortalità in questo momento
per le infezioni antibiotico resistenti
700 mila morti nel mondo prima causa
tumori
cosa ci dice quella pallina rossa
intorno alle infezioni antibiotico
resistenti che nel 2050 se noi non
facciamo nulla i morti saranno 10
milioni mentre i morti per tumore
continuano a diminuire quelli per
infezioni antibiotico resistenti
continuano a salire e sarà la prima
causa di mortalità come possiamo fermare
tutto questo abbiamo detto a linea
all'inizio che resistenti agli
antibiotici non si nasce ma sicuramente
si diventa e io vorrei aggiungere che lo
si diventa solo se noi rimaniamo fermi a
guardare e se voi non esercitate il
vostro diritto di libera scelta
grazie
[Applauso]